attention cette vidéo ne va pas être
très amusante bien au contraire mais
j'ai besoin de la faire vraiment ça me
fait du bien il faut que j'aie
extériorise des choses que je pense
hier je suis allée chez youtube pour
aller chercher le bouton des 10 millions
d'abonnés il est ici voilà bravo
il vous appartient autant qu'à moi en
vrai tout ça c'est grâce à vous c'est
juste un objet il fallait que j'aille le
chercher
c'est un symbole mais en fait c'est pas
pour ça que je fais cette vidéo c'est
plus pour ce qui a suivi à savoir hier
soir j'ai posté une photo du coup je
suis avec ce bouton en disant merci quoi
parce que c'est vraiment c'est fou
puisque je vis c'est incroyable j'ai une
chance exceptionnelle on va y venir
juste après et est s ous et post j'ai
reçu des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de commentaires mais tellement
gentil les commentaires les plus
touchants les plus sincères et les mieux
rédigé que j'ai pu voir de toute ma
carrière et ça m'a tellement touchée
vous savez moi je vous le dis en toute
transparence que j'ai pleuré dans ma
baignoire nu dans ma baignoire à j'ai
pleuré dans ma baignoire au fait de me
doucher tout simplement et je me suis
mis à pleurer parce que j'ai réalisé à
quel point c'est complètement incroyable
ce qui m'arrive et je pense que 1,1
humain n'est pas fait pour recevoir
autant d'amour dans la gueule d'un coup
comme ça vraiment j'ai besoin de faire
cette vidéo pour extérioriser sa et pour
vous leur envoyez l'amour parce que vous
êtes diminuons mais quand diminue on
m'envoie de l'amour mais je suis seul
derrière et c'est de ça fait très
bizarre vraiment vais pas me passer des
messages vous lire des messages parce
que c'est des gens qui m'ont écrit des
trucs très personnel et ça se partage
pas mais croyez moi c'est des choses
vraiment pur sincère et en fait ça m'a
juste fait réaliser à quel point j'ai un
impact sur la vie des gens à quel point
je peux les pousser à donner le meilleur
d'eux mêmes à traverser les problèmes
avoir l'avis du meilleur angle possible
en fait tout simplement et ça va
vraiment j'ai vraiment réalisé ça hier
j'étais hyper lucide avec tous ces
commentaires là et ça m'a fait un bien
exceptionnel même - en fait ça m'a fait
relativiser à fond en fait c'est sur
youtube on a toujours des phases de
doute on veut toujours donner le
meilleur de nous mêmes faire mieux faire
mieux que les autres aussi on oublie je
trouve que l'important en fait c'est
juste qu'on fait voyager des gens on
leur fait oublier plein de choses on
leur fait apprendre des choses on leur
fait passer des moments géniaux et tout
ça depuis sept ans en fait j'ai vraiment
reçu des messages de gens qui m'ont dit
mec j'ai grandi avec toi quand tu avais
14 ans j'avais 14 ans aussi mais
maintenant on a tous les deux la
vingtaine et je continue à regarder ce
que tu fais et je trouve ça fou de
grandir
virtuellement avec des gens d'avoir
versé un peu leur adolescence et tout je
trouve ça sain agréable et je n'avais
jamais pris conscience de sa j'oublie
très souvent le passé je m'en souviens
pas assez et là ça m'a mis une gifle
monumentale dont j'ai pas préparé de ce
pitch ou deux trucs à lire ou quoi
j'avais juste besoin de vous parler
vraiment quoi parce qu'en fait j'ai eu
les dix millions d'abonnés et j'ai rien
fait parce que ma vidéo 10 millions
d'abonnés elle l est pas prête tout
simplement
elle arrivera en juin je vais la tournée
en mai ça va être deux semaines de
tournage ça va être fabuleux ça va être
trop bien mais je voulais pas faire une
vidéo ou jeudi eh ben elle arrive en
juin
à demain pour une autre vidéo je
trouvais ça un peu bizarre du coup j'ai
rien fait mais j'ai quand même ce truc
de mais c'est quand même un cap
de fouet c'est quand même important d'en
parler de faire un petit point de
d'extérioriser tout ça parce que c'est
beaucoup pour un mec de 22 ans que je me
penche pas si vous vous rendez compte
enfin en positif 1 mais ma vie elle est
incroyable c'est n'importe quoi
j'ai pas dû passer par des taaf chiant
et pénible c'est j'ai commencé youtube
j'avais 15 ans j'étais vraiment très
jeune c'était beaucoup pour moi et je
pense qu'à la base je n'avais pas du
tout les épaules pour supporter un truc
pareil parce que voilà on est personne
on a une personne publique
on est sous les projecteurs on est jugé
ce qui est normal bien évidemment mais
on n'est pas forcément prêt à tout ça et
chaque rencontre que j'ai fait que ce
soit des amis youtuber des amis tout
court oovoo m'a permis aujourd'hui
d'être ce que je suis et d'avoir la vie
que j'ai et je suis très content de ça
vous imaginez pas en fait comme vous
m'avez aidé à me construire moi-même à
un âge où j'étais parfaitement instable
psychologiquement et où j'avais besoin
de sa dette pour me construire et vous
m'avez vraiment aidé sur ça et ça j'en
ai jamais parlé mais je le pense
vraiment aujourd'hui je suis comme ça
parce que j'ai vécu ça parce que vous
avez choisi de regarder mes vidéos parce
que vous m'avez envoyé des messages
parce que je vous ai croisé en
convention parce que je vous ai fait des
câlins tout ça ça a aidé à construire ma
personnalité et à construire ce que je
suis aujourd'hui et c'est juste dingue
si je pouvais revenir dix ans en arrière
et dire aux petits lutins qui joue à
dofus mec t'inquiète à 12 heures avec
les filles t'es un gros geek personne te
comprends autour de toi mais t'inquiète
continue parce que dans dix ans il y
aura 10 millions de personnes qui sont
abonnées et conquis fais ce que tu as
fait et bien franchement c'est le petit
lucas il serait tellement sur le cul
comprendraient pas et du coup ça a
changé tout mon destin et ça se trouve
je finirai pas du tout
voilà j'ai pas à pas grand chose de plus
à dire à part juste merci merci merci je
pensais pas mais ce de boutons du
coup c'est parce que je les ai reçus que
hier j'ai eu un vrai choc de fou après
la photo vous m'avez envoyé mais des
vagues d'amour mais mais j'ai jamais vu
ça mais c'est incroyable c'est fou la
mort j'ai reçu hier ça m'a mis sur le
cul et même là encore aujourd'hui ça
continue et je suis vraiment ému en
voyant tout ça et j'ai besoin d'en
parler
ok j'ai besoin d'extérioriser mon petit
coeur effet lucas ya trop d'amour pour
un seul homme
ce n'est pas possible de gérer ça
renvoie le attention en tout cas sachez
que depuis que j'ai arrêté de me forcer
à faire des vidéos depuis que j'en fais
moins que j'en fais deux par semaine au
lieu de quatre je suis tellement plus
épanouie mais vraiment j'ai toujours des
petites phases de doutes des petits mais
c'est normal tous les créatifs on ça
mais voilà je vais juste vous faire un
message sincère je pense que
j'appellerais la vidéo un message
sincère ouais c'est pas mal du coup
c'est bien beau tout ça mais là c'est un
peu que dans un sens ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est je témoigne
juste de la mort vous m'avez apporté
mais moi ce que j'aurais à vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est juste voyez le positif
essayer de toujours voir le positif même
quand il y en a très peu il ya forcément
une brindille du positif on peut
toujours se dire ça aurait pu être pire
même quand c'est désastreux on peut
quand même se le dire vraiment moi comme
je vous ai dit je peux vous donner tous
les conseils que je veux mais je suis
pas légitime j'ai une vie jusqu'à
présent ccg trop de chance j'ai vraiment
une chance exceptionnelle
donc je serai pas trop quoi vous donner
comme conseil parce que vous avez plus
de vue que moi et vous avez probablement
plus d'expérience que moi souci vous
avez huit ans mais voilà concentrez-vous
sur le positif
accrochez vous à vos passions foncé
quand vous dit le fait pas eh ben dites
vous avez peut-être qu'il faut le faire
du coup puisqu'on a dit pas le faire
mais sur une musique ça atteint en plus
j'ai entendu c'est vrai ça le progrès
dit ça dans une musique mais c'est
vraiment ce que je pense parce que je
n'ai vécu ce truc-là de je veux aller
dans une direction et on me dit non non
non fait pas fait pas fait pas et j'ai
quand même fait regarder la chambre en
juin
énormément de chance il ya plein de gens
qui sont nés dans la même direction et
qui n'ont pas eu le même parcours que
moi qui ai eu moins de chance et ça n'a
pas marché pour eux et c'est triste mais
voilà fait ce qu'il faut pour être
heureux concentrez-vous sur le positif
et envoyer de l'amour à vos proches aux
gens qui vous entourent entourez-vous
bien de bonnes personnes
il ya beaucoup d' dans ce monde
mais il y aussi beaucoup de bonnes
personnes on a tendance à l'oublier et à
voir que le négatif
et ça je vous dis je les ai vécu pendant
des années voire que négatifs mais
aujourd'hui j'arrive à voir vraiment que
le positif et puis voilà je pense pas
que j'ai beaucoup d'autres trucs à dire
je t'assure j'avais rien préparé je suis
là larache mai
j'en profite je fais pas beaucoup de
vidéos où je parle comme ça et ce que
j'ai autre chose à dire bah non non non
je crois que c'est bon ça fait du bien
ça fait du bien j'ai bien fait je suis
content plein de bisous à vous portez
vous bien passé un très bon week end
on se retrouve dimanche pour une
prochaine vidéo et j'espère que cette
vidéo là vous aura pas trop fichiers et
puis si c'est le cabba météo on pousse
rouge et je me fais des bisous à 13h21
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chef